Comment je vais bien pouvoir fabriquer une centrale nucléaire avec ça et peut-être déjà vu des vidéos
j'achète de l'uranium sur internet c'est cool hein t'as vu ça fait du bruit qu'ils font peur
mais derrière j'ai l'impression qu'on peut pas faire grand chose de plus
j'ai enquêté avec mon ami quantum et aujourd'hui on va faire un truc d'agent secret un truc jamais vues sur youtube
vous emmène dans l'un des endroits les plus sécurisés au monde un site d'enrichissement d'uranium
C'est vrai mais on va pas mettre ça on est pas beau
pour toi
Enfin quand on parle d'uranium on dirait un peu vous avez un truc dangereux genre
l'uranium mois on pense aux truffes vert fluorescent qui va te donner
huit bras et 4 testicules si tu t'en approche et on pose aussi et surtout vous fait que s'est créée par l'homme c'est un truc
et un chimiques bien artificiel dégueulasse sauf que l'uranium ça se trouve vachement et surtout à l'état naturel
mais après c'est tellement facile à trouver tu peux en trouver en 10 secondes même sur internet mais une question demeure comment ce qu'on passe
du caillou à la centrale à l'énergie finale qu'on va utiliser et bien c'est là que le centre va nous apporter toutes les réponses
je vous propose d'enfiler nos plus belles combinaisons jaunes dégueulasse et de nous suivre dans la centrale du tricastin
je sens prêt je veux toucher de rap il y toucher du nucléaire
Et
Absolument rien
Là dedans
plusieurs dizaines de tonnes d'uranium enrichi et ce qui va se passer un
échantillon de 4 kg peut être élevée que nous allons prélever et qu'on va emmener au
laboratoire pour analyse de l'échantillon croyez-le ou non mais je suis actuellement en train de porter trois échantillons
d'hexafluorure d'uranium
c'est le composé qui sert à faire belle et les combustibles des centrales nucléaires en france et je tiens ça à peu près
5 cm de mon visage mais tout va bien fourni
J'adore il panique derrière celle là tout comme aux
écoutes chez c'est du travail de la détermination c'est
un peu la première étape avant d'être gelée depuis dorman finalement lassé mais pourquoi enrichir l'uranium
comme vous l'avez vu sur notre vidéo de l'uranium y en a beaucoup
même dans son jardin le truc c'est que seul un certain type d'uranium nous intéresse l'uranium
235 et il y en a pas beaucoup
0,7 pour cent du total de l'uranium sur terre enrichir ses proches de l'uranium
essayé d'enlever l'uranium 235 de l'isoler de le concentrer pour en avoir un maximum si vous avez 100 % d'uranium
ce étrange re 1 ça fait de jolis explosion
heureusement c'est interdit par toutes les lois internationales
par contre 3% 3 % c'est pas beaucoup
3% c'est stable et ça va permettre de produire beaucoup d'énergie pour plein de foyers ce que vous connaissez vous c'est le premier état de
d'uranium l'uranium comme ceux ci le métal c'est l'élément classique celui que vous imaginez dans le tableau périodique des éléments
l'uranium tout simple il va d'abord être sous cette forme c'est ce qu'on appelle le yellow cake
cette espèce de poudre jaune en tout surnom qui va être d'abord dans cet état pour être
transporté des mines vers les premiers sites de traitement vient ensuite l'étape de l'enrichissement de l'uranium
l'uranium on peut pas l'utiliser comme thème et pour l'enrichir on va utiliser des atomes de fluor
c'est à dire les mêmes at home continue dans votre dentifrice
on va donc lui coller dans un premier temps quatre atomes de fluor pour obtenir ce tétrafluorure d'uranium
d'une couleur un peu un peu verte c'est la couleur qu'on imagine des produits nucléaires
et ensuite dans un second temps
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui est principalement fait sur ce site on l'enrichît une seconde fois en y rajoutant à nouveau deux atomes de fluor pour
obtenir de l'hexafluorure
d'uranium
alors évidemment on vous en doutez c'est un faux anti tueur production parce qu'ici c'était un vrai jeu sera en grand danger étant donné que
ce produit est très corrosif et radioactifs hexafluorure d'uranium retenez bien ce nom c'est la matière la plus
importante pour l'enrichissement ça permet de transformer l'uranium qui est remis talent ça lourd en
un gaz et ce à très faible température
64° et vu que c'est gazeux c'est plus facile de séparer les différents types d'uranium c'est aussi une question de sécurité
parce que si le gaz s'échappe dans l'air à l'uranium on retombe
directement au sol c'est donc plus sécurisé et c'est pour ça qu'on le transporte et qu'on le vend comme ça à
l'international alors tellement nabili
tout les gens là qui était contenu qui était né de l'idée dont on a vu qu'il y avait quasiment rien de la coupe veut
l'emporter parce que j'entendais ya mon rappelle qu' un couple craque médias gasquet montre un peu le champ en milieu
de
grille aux radios qui donc est
ce qu'on va faire du coup on pas s'approcher d'un dea
En montrant cette vidéo à mes amis j'ai eu des mais là tu fous mais qu'est-ce que ça fout dehors les bidons sont blindées enfermé
dans un sarcophage
à l'intérieur la matière est solide sans fuite possible et surtout c'est pas très radioactifs en fait on avait poussé la machine à fond
comme vous voyez sur la vidéo les rayonnements sont deux très courtes distances et faut
vraiment s'y coller pour que ça crie alors à ce moment-là on voulait voir l' usine qui permet d'enrichir l'uranium
savez c'est immense tube qu'on voit sur les photos
rousset des grosses turbines ou home et l'hexafluorure d'uranium
et chaque tube va filtrer de plus en plus le radium pour avoir nos 3 % de concentration
lusinchi fait ça les toutes nouvelles c'est georges besse 2 et malheureusement pouvait pas la visiter
c'est top secret mais s'il ya eu 1 2 il y a eu un numero uno
georges besse 1 c'est l'ancienne usine et l on a pu la visiter
en urbex en exploration n'a pu se faufiler là dedans et c'était très beau
hockey laval entre là dans la partie il y avait tous les anciens
jeux les anciennes machines énormes et d'après ce qui est écrit sur la porte
les deux pour ta vidéo
ok par contre j'ai entendu un bruit alors qu'on met tout seul
Que quatre ans
Ici il régnait une chaleur infernale
des centaines de degrés dans lequel des hommes et des femmes travaillent et une usine grandiose mais qui va bientôt disparaître
elle a fait son temps et elle sera bientôt détruite on a peut-être été parmi les derniers à avoir ça sur terre
coucou alors c'est vrai que la suppression sera courte mais on est dans un endroit assez
exceptionnel
la taille des machines qui sont au dessus nous ce qu'on a vu tout à l'heure quand on était au dessus sur la vitre et
menant à redescendre un peu lentement c'est vraiment très très très très ouf si c'est vraiment enfin
six et abandonner que fins abandonné c'est plus utilisé que depuis 2012 mais ça a été construit à partir de 70
et il a fait tomber en ce moment historique qui pèse là sur toutes les machines est-ce que je lâche un dab
un des menus clairs le dit mais c'est vrai qu'on soit que le fait qu'on soit tous seuls entièrement dans
dans toute leur ca la science et ça donne vraiment
à côté un peu mystique à l'endroit c'est c'est très bizarre
bon bonne nouvelle c'est que mon deuxième être n'a pas l'air de
de relever que ce soir je repars donc normalement on n'a pas notre numéro seront n'ont toujours pas donc on n'est toujours pas contaminer donc
on va continuer à chercher des moyens de se faire contaminer on dirait un gland en fait non un peu
à part un peu un gland après ça et malgré le vent ultra violent on a pu visiter un endroit qui me fascine
ok bon derrière nous on a les deux fameux
énormissime tours aéroréfrigérantes
c'est vous savez le presque le symbole les tours symboles des centrales nucléaires et ce qui va se passer mais
c'est qu'on va aller dedans et on va essayer de faire voler un drone
s'est pas déjà et fantômes 3
Ce que chillingo gros
Tu fais le boulot oh la la c'est tellement bon
Monsieur
Et
C'est là toute la vie c'est david lappartient ok mone
Si on peut monter sa petite échelle noir pouvoir pour faire décoller le drone
si on fait des clubs en fait on a un drone qui est super légers
super fragile dans paraître vu qu'il ya énormément de mistral dehors
le mistral s'engouffre par dessous dans la tour et du coup ça fait un
cours en montant à l'aide qu'on a peur c'est un drone qui déjà de lui n'est pas à nous et qui de 2 et super
légers on a peur que le drone s'envole et qu'on le perde complètement donc
d'un côté on est tellement excité qu'on veut on veut des plans de cet endroit c'était super vous même temps c'est pas si on
on risque le drone
ya donc ouais effectivement
il ya un truc important c'est que comme vous voyez c'est ici qu'on mettait le réacteur nucléaire non j'rigole criant n'a pas en fait
c'était juste pour l'eau c'est quand l'eau à la vapeur elle se refroidit c'est comme ça la retombée elle pouvait être réutilisées
donc en fait qu'est-ce qu'il sort des tours de l'eau
alors
comme ça je pensais vraiment que j'allais rencontrer des scientifiques
fous et des militaires une trame nerfs alors pour les militaires peut-être mais en ce qu'il s'agit des
scientifiques et des opérateurs il s'agit alors tout ça
c'était des crèmes des gens qui étaient fascinés par leur métier mais ça fait toujours plaisir à voir
alors quand je suis arrivé là bas j'ai plein de questions du plein de réponses
comptant plus de questions je sais plus où moins fabriquer marty centrales nucléaires la maison
tout évidemment poussé long il ya beaucoup de chimie vous citez vous
quelques petites vidéos en tuto il ya un mètre sur internet qui est allé très loin quasiment à l'exacte jours durant un
garçon trouve je voulais aussi remercier aura nos pour nous avoir aidés sur cette vidéo ils ont été très cool ils ont laissé
carte blanche mais en tout cas on a pu faire beaucoup de choses
très étonné mais agréablement surpris
vous le 6 remercier tous les hommes et les femmes qui nous ont accueillis sur leur lieu de travail ils vont pas souvent des buteurs
c'est pas genre van doren ya des bêtes et des caméras cublac souvent merci à eux j'espère avoir aiguisé votre curiosité
d'avoir montré des trucs qu'on voit pas souvent sur youtube et surtout vous avoir donné envie d'explorer ce monde
je vous remercie encore m'avoir donné la possibilité de
aller mais vu qu'on a fini d'être journée tout en fait on a décidé d'aller à la ferme aux crocodiles de pierrelatte
on va voir des crocodiles
Dans la même journée j'aurais quand même été à côté d'uranium radioactif dangereux et
de piranhas je pensais pas beaucoup quand sur terre qui peut le dire cette phrase